i think it's roger penrose that think
that information can bleed through
from before the big bang to the after
the big bang yeah is that uh is the big
bang uh
like a full erasure of the hard drive or
is there some information that could
bleed through yeah i mean so sir roger
is among the most creative thinkers of
the last 100 years rightly
won the nobel prize for his insights
into uh singularities in space time that
we know to afflict our mathematical
solutions of black holes in the big bang
and so forth and um
he has an enormously fertile imagination
and and i mean that in the most positive
sense and
so he has put forward this idea this
conformal cyclic cosmology i think is
the the official title although i could
be getting that wrong
i can't say that i've studied it i have
seen
lectures on it i don't find it
convincing as yet it feels
like it's being
built
to find a solution as opposed to sort of
more naturally emerging
um maybe roger would say otherwise and i
don't mean to in any way
um uh cast aspersions on the work it's
it's vital and interesting and people
are thinking about it i don't consider
it as close a competitor
to say the inflationary theory as for
instance the stuff that
paul steinhardt has put forward but
again you've got you got to keep an open
mind in this in this business when
there's so much that we don't yet
understand i mean it is wild to think
that information can survive something
like that just like
it is wild to imagine that information
could escape a black hole for example or
it just seems like
by construction these things are
supposed to not
bleed out anything but one of the
challenges in all these theories is when
we talk about a singularity has this
really sexy term the singularity yeah
but a singularity is is in more ordinary
language
a physical system where the mathematics
breaks down
it's nonsensical
it's like taking one divided by zero you
put that into a calculator and it says e
error right it does not make sense
doesn't compute and and so it's very
hard
to
make
definitive statements about things like
the big bang or about black holes until
we cure the mathematical singularities
and there are some who claim that in
certain regimes the singularities have
been cured
i don't by any means think that there's
consensus on these ideas so when one
talks about information sort of bleeding
through the big bang you've really got
to make sure that the equations have no
singularity you talk about cyclic
cosmology you've got to make sure that
the equations don't have any
singularities as you go from say one
cycle to the next now some of the
proponents of these theories claim that
they have resolved these issues i i
don't think that there's a general sense
that that is the case as yet but it
could be that look i
life is so short that i i haven't had
the time to deeply delve into all the
mathematical intricacies of all the
ideas that have been put forward if i
did that i'd never do anything else but
that that's what the issue is and of
course it's just math there may be holes
there may be uh there may be gaps in our
understanding in the way we're modeling
physical variables well that's the point
in fact when you said i was about to
jump in and say modeling but you got
there first and it's exactly the right
point
we're talking about the universe here
yeah right and the
how do you how do you talk about the
universe with a straight face
mathematically and the way you do it is
you you simplify
you throw away those characteristics of
the universe that you don't think are
vital to a full understanding and so
we're going to get to a point people are
starting to where we've got to go beyond
those simplifications
and so cosmology has for a long time
modeled the universe in the most
simplest terms homogeneous isotropic
it has just a few parameters that
describe it the average density of mass
and energy and so forth we have to go
beyond those simplifications and that
will require
putting these things on computers we're
not going to be able to do calculations
there so much as astrophysics has gone
beyond many simplifications to now give
really detailed simulations of star
systems and galaxies and so forth we're
going to have to do that with cosmology
and people are starting to do that today
you